[Música]
de Walter riso Se podría decir
fácilmente que es el autor más vendido o
mejor el terapeuta más vendido y una
persona que además ha transformado en
género como conocemos como de autoayuda
en algo más en algo que va más allá y
esto por supuesto no es ninguna
casualidad Walter riso pues hay que
decirlo en su perfil es doctor en
psicología es especialista en terapia
cognitiva en bioética ha tenido su
consultorio es famoso por sus
conferencias y por sus muchos libros
sobre trabajo emocional en las personas
sin embargo puede que esto esté de más
para muchos de nuestros televidentes
porque basta con ir a una librería para
encontrar muy fácil sus publicaciones y
además su nombre también surge
frecuentemente en las consultas de
terapia con esa presentación Walter
Bienvenido a France 24 gracias gracias
Un gusto para mí estar aquí
estoy a tu disposición Bueno pues
empecemos entonces
me llaman varias cosas la atención de
sus publicaciones Walter y quiero que
empecemos Hablando de su último libro
que es de tanto amarte Me olvidé de mí
cuando empecé a leer este libro fue
evidente para mí que usted utiliza mucho
los ejemplos con mujeres no esta mujer
que sufrió una situación una paciente
que me contó etcétera etcétera
[Música]
al recurrir a estos ejemplos quisiera
preguntarle Usted qué opina sobre un
concepto como el feminismo Usted cree
que este concepto podría ayudarnos a
evolucionar en un enfoque para promover
la salud emocional pues no me cabe duda
Pero la razón a ver hay dos aristas para
analizar ahí una es la ideológica y la
política y la otra es la psicológica
ideológicamente y políticamente estoy
con el feminismo
y lo he demostrado a lo largo de todos
mis años de trabajo pienso que las
mujeres más inteligente emocionalmente
que los hombres
acude más fácilmente a la ayuda
psicológica sin tantos prejuicios al
hombre que llevarlo a la fuerza
en general creo que si ustedes manejaran
el mundo
el mundo sería mejor pero no es que no
hubiera corrupción habría pero menos
Pues fíjate que yo estoy de acuerdo con
usted Bueno me encanta y en la segunda
en la otra pregunta de lo psicológico es
porque el 85% de mis pacientes de mis
estudiantes de mi lectoras son mujeres
tengo dos hijas mujeres no tengo hijos
hombres Tengo
dos hermanas mujeres no tengo hermanos
hombres me he creado en un ambiente
femenino entonces tengo un femenino
interior muy fuerte que a veces se cruza
con un Mel Gibson de Corazón Valiente y
a veces no sé cómo manejarlo bueno Y
usted cree que es por eso que tantas
mujeres lo buscan en su consulta
porque literatura el punto de vista del
compañero hombre no es protagonista
incluso muchas veces juega el papel de
Villano Por decirlo de alguna manera y
usted me corrige Pues si estoy
exagerando
que ha encontrado en su escritura para
mujeres porque usted está escribiendo
desde antes de los 90 Cómo ha
evolucionado pues nuestra propia imagen
en nuestro nuestro nuestro concepto de
salud emocional como mujeres mira en
1991 yo escribí un libro que se llamaba
intimidades masculinas cuando el libro
salió en Puerto Rico
había un cartel que decía lea el libro
del hombre que renegó de los hombres
porque yo proponía Y esto es muy
importante y lo propongo
un antihéroe Yo propongo un manifiesto
Liberación masculina Pero entonces las
mujeres me decían más liberación de la
que ustedes tienen pero es que mi
Liberación son los es lo patriarcal para
mí Los patriarcales insoportable yo no
quiero transmitir el apellido
Yo quiero tener el derecho ser impotente
Yo quiero tener el derecho a ser pobre
Yo quiero tener el derecho a expresar
emociones quiero tener derecho a ser la
paz y no la guerra es decir y así
sucesivamente Pues eso que usted dice
tiene un nombre y se llama masculinidad
frágil no que es además un término que
está muy de moda por estos días pero que
poco es practicado en la realidad no Y a
partir de esas masculinidades Claro pero
a partir de esas masculinidades frágiles
pues Cómo podemos generar cambios porque
la gente todavía aparece no entenderlo
en el común pero para mí no es frágil
para mí es una nueva masculinidad
eso empieza en el Canadá bueno y allá
por los noventa y picos yo ya empecé con
eso sí Entonces no es que el hombre sea
Villano
quiero aclarar eso en una parte de mi
libro que digo de quién no te deberías
enamorar
pero si uno toma los los científicamente
hablando los patrones de desorden de la
personalidad
en todos los casos el 95% son hombres
menos la parte histriónica que se lo
comparten hombre y mujeres si yo tomo el
narcisista el 95% son hombres ahora con
la con la ruptura del techo de cristal
de mujeres que han entrado al poder y
ellas empiezan a ver mujeres narcisistas
pero son mucho los hombres si yo tomo el
trastorno psicopático es mucho más si yo
tomo y así sucesivamente Entonces los
ejemplos que yo pongo son ejemplos
primeros que nacen de mis pacientes
que nacen de mi experiencia personal y
de la parte de la docencia cuando
investigamos no lo que Define una pareja
no me gusta la palabra tóxica no la voy
a usar ya lo usé me gusta la palabra
mejor disfuncional las parejas
disfuncionales son una mujer dependiente
y un hombre narcisista las mujeres son
más dependientes que los hombres en una
proporción de 6 a 1
bueno eso tiene sentido y también es la
cantidad de hombres más narcisistas que
hay en el mundo si uno tiene en cuenta
que vivimos en un mundo desarrollado
patriarcalmente pues desde sus comienzos
ahora Walter
quisiera preguntarle por su género al
principio de esta entrevista Yo decía
que usted ha transformado este género
porque ha convertido algo que
inicialmente para muchos podría parecer
simplemente una charla ligera en algo un
poco más científico en algo con base en
algo que una persona que tal vez no
tiene el recurso para tomar una terapia
semanal pues puede comprar un libro y
puede sentarse y hacer sus propias
reflexiones a usted le molesta que sea
catalogado todavía como autoayuda o que
en las librerías aparezca dentro de
estas estanterías
a veces no saben dónde colocarme depende
del país que vaya a veces estoy en
psicología a veces estoy en filosofía a
veces estoy en autoayuda a veces estoy
en cualquier otra cosa
Hay una científica que empezó como una
divulgación
Sí y hay otra que no hay otra que sí es
cierto todas las críticas que se le
hacen Entonces yo creo que
no a mí no me molesta también No me
molesta ni cinco porque yo ya yo sé lo
que hago yo creo en mí Y sé que soy
serio
Y que todos mis estudios yo los vuelco a
eso qué hacemos los psicólogos que
hacemos esto bien hacemos prevención es
decir llegamos a la gente con
información
relevante científica que disminuye la
probabilidad futura de que se enfermen o
hacemos promoción de salud que Qué es
crear estilo de vida saludable si yo sé
que el contacto físico en un niño
disminuye la posibilidad de que haga
cuadros depresivos Pues yo tengo que
avisarle a la población
cierto entonces así como el odontólogo
Explica cómo hacer para que no tener
caries el hepatólogo explica Qué hacer
para no tener un cáncer en el hígado
Pues los psicólogos También tenemos que
explicar qué hacer Para no caer en
alguna enfermedad entonces eso se conoce
en psicología como psicología de la
salud Sí eso se ha divulgado de otras
maneras pero digamos que a mí me ubican
Por decirlo así como una persona que
hace
no te ayuda científica
bueno es interesante y bueno Claro que
no tendría que molestarle con todo lo
que le leen Y con todo lo que lo compran
prueba de ello Pues el fruto que son
todas sus publicaciones ahora Ustedes
muy famoso por movilizar a los lectores
en torno al balance saludable que debe
existir en nuestras relaciones y habla
mucho por supuesto de las relaciones
amorosas y aquí le pregunto por qué nos
cuesta tanto todavía hoy en día
identificar las codependencias las
relaciones abusivas Porque son el pan de
cada día Lamentablemente
porque estamos hablando de algo que se
llama adicción
estamos hablando de una zona del cerebro
que genera dopamina en cantidades
industriales Entonces cuando hablamos de
adicción hablamos
si quieres un término más budista de
apego o hablamos de dependencia no
entonces una adicción
corrompe no solo existe la corrupción
política también existe la corrupción
psicológica porque cuando tú estás
adicta a una persona o algo
tú harías cualquier cosa para no
perderla y empiezas a negociar con tus
principios lo que podemos ver en la
evolución Que es que en la posmodernidad
hay un androgenia social las mujeres y
los hombres están juntando en cuanto a
los roles sociales sobre todo en las
democracias del primer mundo Entonces en
esa androgenia la mujer y el hombre
adoptan papeles similares pero Pese a
que tengan valores que no tenían
nuestras abuelitas como la autonomía
como la territorialidad la independencia
en términos de libertad sigue existiendo
la dependencia emocional no ha mejorado
las estadísticas Entonces
igual que las estadísticas de la
dependencia sexual en comparación de
hombre mujeres que es de 90 a un 10
entonces lo que estamos viendo Es que
todavía falta Sí entonces una adicción
no se cura por decirlo así porque
alguien te explica que es una adicción
ahí lo que tiene que hacer uno es pedir
ayuda profesional si tú eres adicta Love
adicción a tus a tu pareja lo que vas a
hacer es que la balanza de la
reciprocidad se incline una pendiente
resbaladiza y se vuelve a vertical y ya
se convierte en una relación dominancia
de sumisión sí O sea que romper la
dependencia e ir hacia una a un desapego
a una Independencia emocional es salvar
la dignidad personal
Pues mira Walter en mi círculos cercanos
Yo siempre digo que los libros son
salvadores Y por qué no más aún cuando
pueden aportar a una persona que
necesita trabajar en su salud emocional
y dicho esto esa persona somos todos
Porque todos tenemos trabajo que hacer
Así que pues Yo le agradezco mucho Le
agradezco mucho por su tiempo por
escribir Le deseo que siga escribiendo y
que siga cosechando muchos frutos ha
sido un placer bueno Muchas gracias y
Seguiremos con ustedes a través de
nuestra programación de France 24 y de
directo a América quédense con nosotros